[Music]
we're at the Havana Club rum Museum this
is Gretel thank you for having us this
is a museum dedicated to the history of
the production of rum the making of rum
here in Cuba exactly
so we begin the tour yes please follow
me okay
[Music]
over here you have part of our iconic
products CEO name is rose gran reserva
and maximum this is the maximal some
people consider this the very best of
the rums is that correct yes how much
would this cost this bottle around
$2,000 this is $2,000 a bottle that's
incredible
can you help me move this into my car
you help is your nightmare that a thief
comes into the night and he drills a
hole in the top like Tom Cruise in
Mission Impossible and then he puts a
straw down steals it to think about
something to think about our room is
made with the with human molasses of
course and the molasses this honey's are
extracted from the sugarcane juice this
is fascinating there's a part where I
just get to drink rum isn't there yes we
must learn history first and then the
rum the sugarcane juice was boiled in
these boilers after it was extracted in
this Mills that was interesting but I
couldn't help so we get someone to paint
this up please
you can see this is extremely hot
boiling molasses it's it's bubbling over
extremely dangerous and
[Music]
just kidding just bubbles was that fun
okay we're now at another section of not
the rum tasting is that correct and I
see you over here this is the last
person to try and get rum on the rum
tour he's petrified frozen solid a long
wait
gets more interesting now because we're
going to see how well you've just said
that it seems like you didn't believe it
gets more interesting now okay
what happens next okay okay you know
what you need you need some run
we're gonna we're gonna go to the bar
now my god it means to see it's only
been eight hours sick this is a flight
of different Havana Club rum exactly so
we're going to start with the three
years this is three years yes the
lighter the rum the more it's used in
cocktails so it's rare that someone
would drink this straight
well yes yeah it's a bit strong so give
it a shot hey yeah it's very good now
we're gonna get a little darker yes the
seven years bit sweeter and you're going
to notice hints of vanilla in it yes
you're right this is getting darker I'm
in my vision
this is 45% alcohol the triple aged rum
that is very smooth I'm getting a little
bit of the oak of the barrel and urine
in my pants which one is this oh this is
the 15 years oh it's good
I see 12 4 we met 8 hours ago I love you
but I love everybody in Cuba I love the
people I love only me
these are my friends you're not my
friend these are my friends they stuck
with me
your rum is the best one
can I stay here until the rum comes the
United States do you have a place I
could stay
I have adult house I don't care I'll
stay in your dog house well would you
sing to me Gretel I'm just thinking me a
Cuban song well please battle sing a
song okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm going to live with Brett oh I'm
going to move in with Brad I'll do the
laundry she will let me have free wrong
I'll change my name to hand so we'll be
back so I grab
we go gray
Ave Domino haha
when drinking responsibly it's always
important to have a designated driver
you
you